MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Getting a budget alert
when your Google Cloud Platform
costs exceed your budget
is a great way to stay on
top of your cloud costs,
but cost controls are
more about [? than ?]
just avoiding billing surprises.
It's also important to
provide the flexibility
you need to scale and have a way
to restrict unnecessary costs.
On this episode of
"Beyond Your Bill,"
we'll talk about how
programmatic budget
notifications can be
added to your budgets
and give some examples for
setting up advanced cost
controls.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In our previous video, we
went through setting up
budgets and alerts
in the GCP console
which trigger email
notifications.
Since budget alerts are sent to
billing account administrators
and billing account
users, you can easily
control who gets
those notifications.
However, that means you may
need to wait for those people
to talk to the right
teams and investigative
if changes need to be made.
If you want to put more
proactive controls in place,
programmatic budget
notifications
can allow you to run code
based on your budgets.
After choosing a threshold
when setting up a budget,
you can connect a Cloud
Pub/Sub to the budget
where you'll choose a
project and a Pub/Sub topic
to receive notifications.
Once the budget is
published in the Pub/Sub,
you can have any
number of subscribers
that will handle the
notifications such as Cloud
Functions for our example.
If you're not
familiar with Pub/Sub,
think of it as a
simple message handler
which passes on any
events such as budget
updates to any services
that are subscribed to it.
Cloud Functions is a
lightweight way and serverless
way to run code, and it's an
ideal solution for quickly
handling budget alerts.
Any budgets you create
with a Pub/Sub topic
will publish the current
status of a budget
multiple times per day rather
than waiting for a threshold
to be crossed.
With each budget
you set up, you can
have both email notifications
and programmatic notifications.
When setting up advanced
cost controls like this one,
you'll want to make
sure that your finance
teams and your IT
teams work together
since this process
involves both sides.
Once you've got everything
connected with Pub/Sub,
the Cloud Function will
receive notifications
with some important information
such as the billing account
ID, the display
name of the budget,
the most recent
threshold exceeded,
and the amount of your costs
for the scope of the budget.
Now that you're writing
code with this information,
you can pretty much do anything
the Google Cloud Platform
API will let you do.
One very common example
is to post an update
to Slack or other
platforms, connecting
any tools your team uses to
stay on top of your costs.
Again, this keeps
people up to date,
but we can also automate
direct cost controls
to respond to these
notifications.
One of the more drastic
actions you can take
is to disable billing
for a project entirely.
For example, you may have a
development or test environment
and a dev team that
constantly spins up
resources in that environment.
If someone on the team spins
up an expensive resource
like a large compute
instance and then
forgets to turn it off, it can
rack up costs pretty quickly.
One way to avoid
this may be to set
a budget and a programmatic
budget notification that
removes the billing
account from the project
after the specific
cost is reached.
It's important to note
that when you disable
billing on a project, all
the billable resources
for that project are shut
down and then deleted.
This is probably
not something you
want to do in a
production environment,
but it can be a quick
way to make sure
that you set a very hard
limit for your costs
on that specified project.
Sometimes a more
nuanced approach
is better, such as limiting
the number of resources
that can be spun up with
quota, or simply stopping
all the compute instances
without deleting them.
That way you're not paying for
them and the appropriate team
can investigate why the usage
was higher than planned.
There's some sample code in the
links below for sending alerts
to Slack, disabling
billing for a project,
and for stopping all
compute instances when you
hit a specified budget amount.
These are great starting
points, and they're
easy to extend with just
a little bit of code
to fit your business needs.
When testing your code, you can
manually send Pub/Sub messages
so that you don't actually have
to wait for the budget amount
to be triggered.
Another driver of unnecessary
or accidental costs
can be from resources that
aren't being used optimally.
Over-provisioned
resources are larger
than they need to be to serve
their current workloads.
And since this is the cloud,
it can be easier to scale them
down as needed.
Idle or part-time
resources can also
be an easy target
for saving costs
since they can be
stopped or scaled down
when they're not at peak usage.
This can also be automated
on a scheduled basis
such as regularly looking
for resources that aren't
being used and removing them.
Two great examples of
this are linked below.
Both walk through
taking advanced actions
such as removing unused IP
addresses and attached disks,
moving storage buckets to
less expensive storage classes
based on their
usage, and setting up
a schedule to start and stop
Compute Engine instances.
Using programmatic
budget notifications
is another step towards
being able to setup cost
controls that match with
your business needs.
Each business is different,
so the specifics depend
on the amount you're looking to
automate and extend your cost
controls, but the links below
give you a great starting point
and provide some sample code.
Check them out and
get a better handle
on controlling your cloud costs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]